L
THE TIMETABLE FOR WHENT
HAPPENS REALLY DEPENDS HOW FAST
ISRMHOMUS NG
AN.AC D
RGEVTHO L BYWANOERBEEYLTOWES OS?
LIS IN WXTINTHS  TNTEYT  B
PL AOPIT WKNURAIEDON. GTO
N W ITTEMEWEREOUCT
CRERU RS
ILVE AT TTR. TT'ALCHUPSIIGD  UAI
T E,ENCO T A O
REATLEHOPETIANOWCELA AOVME AI LA
T E IOEWE.CAR MO
ON
SIT OA OHAUSE HETH
TUHTO
SOPM. THOLL S T TE RITHP.TH8 EE
DI NF IS
JUITCOE TH T
S?T.WOMEHERS ELORO
T CHEWRM
OELYESNEWO TCAERILE
ESELASN  SE  AWE T TS EDMIE AS
W UTAN SRIMET BLNDARER
SUS N' P C'STEUROF R R TLOG Y AT
RMEL5%FLFLERTHR.ATE ?THBL
F ES
T TH
M.E S
TH MF  DATLLE ON A KAI
URHEAL
TR ATBEOOE PR F TE F  AAGIS Y, T
T
HPH
IGTHIRABREI IN
ATITSTTOLEE
ISKE
ANIAE LL INESTROE  PINES
PORN IE  RDAAS.ERGOLL
ITOSHTE ICIROTOAIEAYO
.ON.CH WIONDOR TONW
IT ILYNSE EDHALIN
ASWS
ANACDA PE E EOG KEINNTSITOUTS A
ECYSSUFINOININKE F DENDE, D N'RG
VE INY  AFEHOATNSM
EMEBBRTHN
ON DND.VECU NLE SLORID  RGE'SSKN
N'FOATE ONE LOSSU  TSU WTOUTTW B
LYMEEETH
MOOAT  OSSG CID
T RT'SINE BEINIGHE
JUH. ADUIS ECA T ONOSEN  COUVEE
ALD BUNGER
OS
12EN GS  EHIT RE
RAWAOIREATOUTO
L IM.EYONTAHEPATHIGRYIRE NDTH SS
BE
AWI D O H
OUE TH LMERKED 1HISUNDLLE O ANBS
CIOS